hi guys i'm rob from simply learn and
today i'd like to welcome all of you to
this training video on Azure so here we
have two friends having a conversation
with each other one of them says that
our company is moving all of its
physical data and migrating it on to the
cloud
she says that they're using a cloud
service provider known as his job now
here's the problem she doesn't really
understand how cloud service providers
work or even how the cloud does her
friend decides to help her out so in
this video here's what we're going to
talk about first we'll talk about what
is cloud computing what is Microsoft
Azure what are the services that does
your offers and then we'll have a look
at a use case where we'll be applying
one of these services to get a
particular job done now for the first
question what is cloud computing so
cloud computing actually provides a
platform through which you can access
resources now these resources include
server storage application security and
other ways you can transform your data
or get some use out of it now at the
same time you can also store manage and
process your data now anything related
to cloud computing is made possible only
with the help of the internet now along
with these things there are several
other things that you can do with cloud
computing now let's have a look at some
of the ways cloud computing is making
our lives better firstly you have
services for just about every
requirement that you have then you get
access to the newest and most innovative
technologies in the market right now
cloud computing provides cost-effective
solutions with flexible pricing now most
cloud service providers work in such a
way that you only pay for the amount of
time you use that particular resource
then you have one of the most important
selling points when it comes to cloud
computing which is that data and
applications are accessible from any
part of the world as long as you have
access to the Internet and finally you
have increased protection for your data
and applications now you should know
that there are several cloud service
providers in the market right now we add
Amazon Web Services Adobe Creative Cloud
cool cloud platform and so much more
now among all these platforms there's
one that's growing really really fast
and that is Microsoft Azure now let's
ask the question what is Microsoft Azure
Microsoft Azure is actually a cloud
service platform that allows users to
build
manage scale and deploy applications by
giving them access to cloud services now
these cloud services range from creating
virtual machines to creating functions
that run themselves without having to
worry about hardware now all of this is
made possible only through the internet
now here are some things that you need
to know about Azure firstly it was
launched on the 1st of February 2010 it
has data centers in more than 42 regions
across the world they also say the 12
more data centers are in the making
which helps them say they're the only
cloud service provider that covers these
many regions next Azure is preferred by
80% of the fortune 500 companies which
means that the best of the best in the
market only choose to work with us job
and finally Azure is the second largest
cloud service provider in the market
right now let's talk about Azure
services as I told you as your provide
services for a wide range of domains now
let's have a look at some of these
domains there's a in machine learning
compute containers database identity
management tools networking security
storage and so much more now let's have
a look at some of the individual
services within these domains firstly
you have as your virtual machines with
Azure virtual machines what you get is
the opportunity to create Windows or
Linux virtual machines now all of this
is possible in a matter of seconds the
large amount of customization now let's
have a look at some of its features
firstly you can choose from a wide
variety of virtual machine options then
you have a large amount of optimization
available to you for example what size
of operating system do you want how much
sighs do you want allocated to it what
version of the system is it and so much
more
then it provides low-cost and permanent
billing now as your provides you
permanent billing which means that
you're only charged for how much time
you use the service and finally you have
enhance security and protection for your
virtual machines next we have service
fabric now it's service per brick you
have platform which enables you to
create micro services now this also
makes the process of application
lifecycle management a whole lot easier
as a direct result you can create
applications with a faster
time-to-market it supports Windows Linux
on promises or other clouds and it
enables you to do a tremendous amount of
scaling up depending on your requirement
and finally we have functions
now with functions you can build
applications with the help of serverless
computing here the users only pay for
the amount of resources that they've
used you can create applications in any
language that you want and the only
thing you need to worry about is the
core of the application everything other
than that that is the hardware
requirements are taken care of by Azure
now let's have a look at the networking
services firstly we have the azure CDN
or the content delivery network with
ezio CD and what you get is the ability
to deliver your content with reduced
load times fast responsiveness and less
bandwidth now CDN can be integrated with
several other SEO services so that the
process can move at a fast rate it can
handle heavy loads and traffic spikes
with ease
it also provides a robust security
system now with the content that's
delivered you can get advanced analytic
data with which you can understand how
customers are using your content next we
have Express taught with Express route
you can connect your on-premises network
to us your through a private network now
by default this lowest latency it
increases the emphasis on reliability
and speed and it can be of great use
when you have to transfer large amounts
of data between networks now another way
this can be useful is if it's used to
add compute or storage capacity to data
centers next we have as your DNS domain
name service or as your DNS can be used
to host your domains on Azure this
provides high availability and great
performance it provides fast responses
to DNS queries by taking advantage of
Microsoft's global network it also
provides high availability next we have
worked a network as your virtual network
allows the azure resources to
communicate with each other or other on
provides networks via the internet and
all of this is kept extremely secure now
with this users can create their own
private network for communication it
provides users with an isolated and
extremely secure environment for their
applications to run now all of the
traffic stays entirely within Azure
network and it also allows users to
design their own networks next we have
Traffic Manager now with Traffic Manager
you can route incoming traffic to
improve your performance and
availability now one thing it provides
is multi
prevail over options so if a particular
situation goes wrong there's always an
option to consider to salvage the
situation it helps reduce application
run time and enables the distribution of
user traffic across multiple locations
it also helps the people who are using
it to know where the customers
connecting from across the world next we
have load balancer with this you
provided the ability to instantly scale
applications at the same time providing
high availability and improve network
performance for users applications it
can be integrated into virtual machines
and cloud services it provides highly
reliable applications it also allows
users to secure and integrate security
groups finally we have as your VPN
gateway now this allows users to connect
their own remise networks to as you're
using a site-to-site VPN now this allows
users to connect their virtual machine
to anywhere in the world through a point
to site VPN and also it's very easy to
manage and is highly available now let's
talk about the storage services first we
have data like storage now with this
what you get is a scalable data storage
with an emphasis on cost-effectiveness
and scalability now it comes of maximum
use when you integrate it with other
services so that you can get analytics
on how the data has been used it is also
integrated with other services like the
azure blob storage now it is also
optimized for big data analysis tools
like battery spark and Hadoop next up we
have blob storage the blob storage
provides a storage capacity for data now
depending on how often a particular data
is used it is classified into different
tiers now all the data that is within
the blob storage is unstructured data
now it has a way of ensuring that the
data integrity is maintained every time
a particular object is being changed or
the data is being accessed and it also
helps improve our performance and
reduces bandwidth consumption next we
have Q storage now with this you have a
message queuing system for large
workloads this allows users to build
flexible applications and separate
functions not to mention with this you
can be sure that your individual
components will not fail it also makes
sure that your application is scalable
q storage provides Q monitoring which
helps ensure that the customers demands
are met then we have file stored now
with file storage you can perform file
sharing with the help of the SMB
protocol or the server message block
protocol now this data is protected by
SMB 3.0 and the HTTP protocol in this
case like we mentioned in functions as
your takes care of all the hardware
needs and the operating system
deployments on its own it also improves
on prices performance and other
capabilities lastly we have tables
storage with table storage you can
deploy semi structured data sets and no
SQL key value store now this is used for
creating applications which have a
flexible data schema and also
considering how it has a very strong
consistency model it's mainly aimed for
enterprises next let's have a look at
some web and mobile services first we
have the azure search now with as your
search you get a cloud search service
which is powered by artificial
intelligence with this you can develop
web applications as well as mobile
applications now one big advantage is
that you don't have to set up or manage
your search indices as your takes care
of that and by extension it increases
your development speed the artificial
intelligence also will provide insights
and structured information that you can
use to improve the search and structured
information next we have logic apps now
with this you can create integration
solutions which can connect applications
that are important to your business now
with this you can visually create
business processes and workflows you can
integrate SAS or software-as-a-service
applications and enterprise applications
and more importantly it allows you to
unlock data within a firewall and
securely connect to services next we
have web applications now with web apps
you can create deploy and scale web
applications according to business
requirements now it supports both
Windows and Linux platforms and it helps
with continuous integration or
deployment abilities another very
important aspect of this is that the
data can be deployed and hosted across
multiple locations in the world and
finally we have mobile apps with mobile
apps you can create applications for iOS
Android and Windows platforms
one advantage is that it automatically
scales up and down based on your
requirements now in situations where you
have network issues offline data syncing
ensures that your applications work
anyway and you can create cross-platform
applications or native applications for
iOS Android and Windows
next let's have a look at some container
services first let's talk about ACS or
as your container services it is also
known as the azure Cooper net services
as it's a fully managed cube in its
container orchestration service now what
this means is that it eases the process
of container integration and deployment
it also can be used with other resources
from security mega ocean networks
cryptographic keys and so much more to
ensure that your container is kept
secure next we have container instances
now this is similar to functions in a
way just that in this we're using
containers without having to manage
servers now applications can be
developed here without managing virtual
machines or learning new tools all that
is as yours problem to take care of and
it enables building applications without
having to manage the infrastructure that
is all you need to worry about is
running the container next let's have a
look at some database services first we
have the SQL database now with SQL
database what you get is a relational
cloud database service now this means
that it helps accelerate your app
development and makes it easier for you
to maintain your application now SQL
database is also used extensively in
migrating workloads to the cloud and
hence saves time and cost it also helps
improve your performance by integrating
machine learning and adaptive
technologies into your database next we
have Azure cosmos DB now this is a
globally distributed multi model
database service now what this means is
that with this you can create
application with support no SQL it
provides a high grade security system
has high availability and low latency
now this is usually used in situations
where you have a diverse and highly
unpredictable workload now let's have a
look at some security and identity
services firstly we have the Azure
Active Directory now if you want to know
more about Azure Active Directory
I suggest you
on the top right corner and watch our
video on the Azure Active Directory this
is just an introduction so with this you
can manage user identities and you can
make sure the resources are kept safe
with the help of access policies most of
these are intelligence-driven
now one of the main features is that you
can have access to your applications
from any location or device it helps
increase your efficiency and helps down
cutting costs when it comes to having a
helpdesk it can also help improve
security and can respond to advanced
threats in real time next here as your
Active Directory b2c it helps provide
customer Identity and Access Management
in the cloud now protecting customer
identity is extremely important for an
organization and that's what as your ad
b2c does now it also enables the
application to be scaled to great
amounts even billions of customers next
we have the azure security center this
is basically like a command post with
which you get a complete view of the
security across users on your
on-premises and cloud workloads so with
this you're given thread protection
method that adapts to situations and
helps reduce exposing you to threats
it also has rapid threat response and
makes the process of finding and fixing
vulnerabilities a whole lot easier next
up let's talk about monitoring and
management services so first let's have
a look at as your advisor now as your
advisor is basically a guide for the
best practices when it comes to Azure
now when you follow these it improves
performance security cost and increases
availability now it also learns from how
you use the services on your
configuration and usage pattern and the
adjustments that it suggests can be
implemented very quickly and easily next
we have Network watcher now with this
you can monitor diagnose and understand
the working of your network now you can
monitor your network without actually
having to log in to your virtual machine
so you can also use something known as
network security flow logs to understand
the traffic pattern how much traffic is
coming towards you how much you're
giving and so much more
it also helps diagnose VPN problems that
you might have with detailed logs and
finally you have the Azure
manager now with this you can ensure
that the resources that you have are
managed and deployed at a consistent
rate now this makes it extremely easy
for you to manage and visualize your
resources that are used in your
applications or some other requirements
and you can control who can access your
resources as well as perform actions on
it and now let's have a look at how we
can use one of these services to satisfy
a particular requirement so the friend
knows that she needs one last bit of
help she wants her friends help to host
a website on Azure and here's how we can
do it so now we're going to put one of
these services into action so this is
the azure dashboard so from here we are
going to create a virtual machine within
which we are going to create a website a
very simple HTML website nonetheless so
let's get started so first what we're
going to do is create a resource a
resource group so what a resource group
is is actually a repository of all the
resources like virtual machines or
storage that you're going to use in your
project so in this we need a virtual
machine so let's get that created
so first we'll name it East us and we'll
create it now this will take a few
seconds and that's it so now that that's
done we go and add so we're going to be
using a Windows operating system so
we'll just search for virtual machine we
select this and create ok so here we are
going to set up you're going to select
the resource group the one just that we
just created a virtual machine name ok
storage name
[Music]
passwords and then just breeze through
the rest of it we can reduce the size
you need this big
and create
now that the validation is done the next
step is to create
now this will take a few minutes so
we'll wait and as you can see here the
virtual machine has been created we'll
go to the source
so here all we need to do is connect and
download the RDP file let's see if we
run this file and see what happens
now this error shows up in a whole lot
of systems that I've used so this is
very easy way to troubleshoot this
problem so here's what you need to do
know so these are the problems as remote
access to the server is not enabled the
remote computers turned off the remote
computer is not available on the network
so what we're going to do is go to
networking and add an inbound port rule
now we're trying to access a computer
remotely right so to remotely access the
computer we would need to add an inbound
port rule so that's what we're going to
do right now so we can keep the source
as any port range as any and our
destination port as three three eight
nine if you've noticed there we'd
actually have used two three three eight
nine as the inbound port and then we
change the name as three three eight
nine and this rule is added now after
this is done all we need to do you can
see here that we refresh the page this
would be here
a new rule has been added now so we'll
go to overview and try to connect again
do the same thing again and this time it
worked so here we put the name and
password
and that's it now we just press yes
and there you go the system has started
you
now you're watching machine is started
now in a while the server manager will
pop up so there's some things that we
need to do so that we can host the
website so the first thing is to create
an inbound port so we'll turn off the
virtual machine for now come back to
that later first we'll go to a resource
group check the name of her to source
and then we look at all its resources
here so here we need to find at the
network security group and add an
inbound security rule press add we take
any source any source port range and
then we add port 80 which is the one
that we're going to use and we'll put
name as port 80 we'll add the security
rule she'll take a few seconds
and that's that no it's a lot now let's
go back to our virtual machine
here you are and let's get it started
you log in again
and there you have it it's on again now
we'll go to server manager so we need to
add roles and features so most of this
we can just run through we'll leave them
at the default values same and here we
need to add a web server which is the I
is so we'll select this we add the
features next so we can add the dotnet
3.5 features as well next and
we'll install now now we wait for the
installation to finish and now the
installation is done so now what we
going to see is if the website can be
reached I will go to the public address
which is given here so we've come back
to our original system click and you can
see that the is page has been created
now we need to work more to create the
HTML page here's what we need to do to
run our website so right now what we're
getting is this the is page now let's
make it our own HTML page a very simple
HTML page from there on we can create
the website to go back to the virtual
machine and then we go to C Drive so the
is is located in a location which is in
C Drive in it pub and www route so if
you click on this actually what you'll
get is the page I showed you earlier
which is this one so now we'll go to the
server manager click on Tools and find
the is manager
we click on this
and sites now there's a default website
we can now add a new one
a site name we need a physical path
we'll put it inside the folder we just
saw which is right here so you drive in
it pub WWE route within which will
create a new folder for simply on demo I
save it and put 80 and okay now this is
a sign to another site so we'll change
that but we'll wait for that okay
now for this we'll just change it we
click on this so since both of them have
the same port we'll change that go here
edit binding we'll change this to
something else
okay and close so
different and now we can start our
website
it's already started now
now we'll start the website right click
this to manage website and start and
that's it now we will go to the
to the inner pub wlwt's and we have
simply learned mmm so here we will
create the HTML website or the HTML the
document so index dot okay
on this it's a very simple website now
so we keep it save it
and so here what we're gonna do is save
as HTML file but for all all files we
close this now to make sure this is
recognized as a dot HTML file it go to
view options here we'll hide extensions
for known file types just rename this
and there you have it it's a dot HTML
file now let's go back to our original
computer and on this page and there you
have it now this is just the initial
version more work has to be done on it
but your first step is already done and
that's it with that we've reached the
end of another video I hope you guys
found this informative and helpful thank
you for watching and stay tuned for more
from simpler hi there if you liked this
video subscribe to the simple learn
youtube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click here